[Music]
joining me today is the author of
several books and the founder and
current president of the David Horowitz
Freedom Center David Horowitz welcome to
the rubric thank you this what are the
chances that you ended up being the
president a place called the David
Horowitz Freedom Center that is better
than quite I actually flip that name but
but my blood said I had I named it the
Center for the Study of popular culture
as a leftist I thought it's a very hard
to attack Center for studying anything
well longest but conservatives see the
word culture and they think left so that
and it was just confusing yeah I mean I
said it's kind of put your name on it so
here we are all right so I don't know in
the years that I've been doing this show
that I've read anyone bio and found it
more interesting than your bio it was at
least not someone that was born in the
United States I thought it was just
there's so much richness there your
evolution politically it has a lot to do
with some of the things that you write
about about going from the left to the
right and all that so I want to start
with your history first your parents
were communist card-carrying
card-carrying everybody we're not
communists like the comment is that kids
that think it's cool today like a no-no
organism is our people are part of a
vast international conspiracy
orchestrated by Moscow um my parents
right I don't think my mother ever got a
traffic ticket they when they were a
very middle class not break the law but
they did hide an East German Communist
in the basement her totally government
wanted to deport I had to get to your
basement and I have no idea I was very
young did you know there was someone
down there I mean did you know Nader was
his name I got the last name his brother
was the mayor of these Berlin okay but
um yeah they were very conspiratorial
they never referred to themselves as
communists only as progressive even then
because it wasn't
dural well oh it was very dirty it was a
dirty word not very healthy period but
because this ni American left very
subversive ready to work with that our
enemies up so you know a horrible
totalitarian dictatorship we're
effectively quarantined we lived in a
kind of ghetto where you couldn't say
what you what you believe that for a
Democrat armed with a small D for a
liberal minded person that doesn't seem
right but it was actually healthy given
the Cold War at the time so so what did
it mean a behind big Hmong people who
hate this country
yeah I mean it we've lost that
completely so so we'll get to that part
because that really sort of that gets to
the evolution part of where you're at
and we were stigmatized and but what did
they believe like what did that actually
mean if you said you were a communist in
you know we're talking the 1940s now I'm
nothing my mother was a registered
Democrat I don't think anything
different from certainly not the
Democratic Party of today although then
I mean when Rosa was president they were
all happy Democrats when Truman declared
that America would defend the people's
fighting for their freedom against the
Soviet Union they all defected that
formed the Progressive Party which was
run by the Communist Party yeah and then
around 1956 if I'm not mistaken all the
information when it comes out about
Stalin and then that sort of light that
was my way I was 17 at the time and that
was my kind of awakening that everything
that the William Buckley who we hated
they right that the right said the right
said Stalin had killed seven million
people he actually killed about forty
million and we said was this was all
anti Soviet lives the Soviet Union was a
paradise of the future everybody equal
everybody working everybody happy all
lies but we my community believed them
and then Khrushchev came along with this
they gave a secret speech that they
Israeli Mossad smuggled out and it just
it blew up my community that and would
divorces you know then and we knew of
other people dividing over the
Khrushchev report people felt betrayed
they had lived a lie and other people
felt you know you continue you go on and
they defended it yeah and that made
marriage is untenable
yeah right you big tub now for marriages
when people are going to love Trump I
hate Trump but but that's a lie at
earth-shaking stuff your whole narrative
yes so I came into the when I went to
college I mean my mission felt felt
developed was to rescue the left from
Stalin ISM I still believed in this
future wherever you know common a
government ownership of the means of
production and quality and everything
and so I I was a fervent new leftist I
was one of them actually one of the
creators of the new left I was at
Berkeley we published a magazine called
branch in uh but by the end of that
decade was clear the left was a
totalitarian force it couldn't and was
supporting it you know whatever was the
man of malice and what malice now killed
more people and spout and so you saw
that change from what you saw something
decent you saw that basically anything
related authorities ISM would be sort of
pieced into this my my most I had two
serious deviations
I had a nuclear family everybody else
was living in
but the more serious one was that I read
books so I I mean I remember when Billy
Ayers was elected vice president whether
whether people took over it SDS is a
college senior he boasted that he hadn't
had a book in a year I was horrified I
the leftist by that statement but what
was that argument was what I'm not being
programmed by these people at all but
they know juji's an irresponsible twit I
mean if you know came from wealth
sorry bringing up privileged I have I am
nothing good to say about Billy Ayers
but by saying I haven't read a book in
here who is he how was he trying to
impress somebody by what I know a breath
well because the books are written by
the ruling class or when a guess what
did Mark say the ruling ideas of the
ideas of the ruling class completely
false how would you explain our
universities today and the marks is full
of crap is the first hunt yeah well
we'll get to our universities know about
that but wait a minute the first one you
mentioned there was you came from a
nuclear family and that was meant a
problem I had a nuclear you had your own
nuclei only right i but it also came
from a new quite the end of the decade i
had four children yeah yeah why was that
a problem for them because they want
David
I wasn't expelled from the left i I was
well well what happened to me was that I
edited ramparts which was the leading it
was the biggest magazine of the left and
a Hollywood producer producer of Easy
Rider um was a big funder and sponsor of
the Black Panther Party and he he
introduced me to Huey Newton because he
wanted me to take Eldridge Cleaver had
been on our masthead and Eldridge it was
a war it was basically a why can't the
party is a street gang and this was a
contest for leadership so he he
introduced me and I got involved raising
money for the pimp
as I raised per school I was very
impressed they had a lot of children and
the Panther Party was a mix they were
you know genuinely good people and they
were gangsters and the good people
impressed me and one of them was running
the school a school and they were jammed
into a brown shingle house and in
Oakland I mean that they had
double-decker beds from one wall to the
other Wow
for the kids so I I thought this
Hollywood producer would give me the
money but it didn't turn out that way I
but I raised I think one hundred and
twenty five thousand dollars it's a lot
of money in those days and bloody church
a Baptist Church in East Oakland that
have been overtaken by the inner city
the white Baptist Church enough and I
signed up the check
I created the Oakland Community Learning
Center a 501 C 3 de house the school
I'll never forget the the minister said
to me as I handed in the check I hope
you're not going to turn this over my
campus combination of Islam I did you
know week that you were working with
them at all to that with the BA happy he
had no idea to know little I have no I
hope into you like most of the left
today I had no idea they were the
Panthers mm-hmm but anyway I told a
story in a radical son my autobiography
anyway in 1974 I I recruited the
bookkeeper
my bookkeeper at grandpa to do the books
for the school because I believed our
own propaganda that the government was
racist and that they would shut down the
Panthers if they didn't keep them books
which was ridiculous I mean look at
Jesse Jackson look at the hell Sharpton
except huge tax evader yeah and he's
walking the streets because these
progressive and Blackie's detected and
in December 1974 Betty
disappeared and by the time the police
district body out of San Francisco Bay
I knew the Panthers had killed there and
I had been interviewed by the police
they explained to me lots of things very
difficult to high to dispose of a body
unless you have an organization and then
if that's a law of safe houses than that
and so when that happened I was
personally devastated I mean I was in
the same place my parents were yeah
being embarrassed by the Christian
report something I swore that I would
never happen to me and I hear parents
around it yeah and my mother was very
they were worried for my safety as they
should be I was threatened by a Elaine
brand with the head of the Panthers is
alive today posted by the Atlanta
journal-constitution and funded by
actually conservative often not always
speak on college campuses she was the
head of the party uh I would
conservatives fund her now as she
evolved I forget that what's the name is
the big Orange County foundation they
gave a ten thousand dollars to speak and
I can't remember with UC Santa Barbara
I was students there informed me now
because conservatives in this country
are well-meaning liberal minded people
generally especially the ones with money
give you the benefit of the doubt I mean
here's a black person claiming that
America's and oppressive country all
sure here's the money
anyway I was personally devastated I was
clinically I would say clinically
depressed for seven eight years I'm
going to wake up in tears any morning I
felt responsible for having recruited
Betty uh her name is Betty van patter
the woman who was murdered she was a
mother of three children the ideology is
so pernicious that on the way that
his funeral her daughter who worked for
me in was fine until she was 19 or 20 at
the time I tried to warn her I mean I
was afraid for my children and I said I
think the Panthers killed your mother
and her response was no they're good
people
so so I set out then to warn when I had
sort of assimilated all this I my
mission was to warn other people and
that's how I know that Barack Obama is a
communist all right so a let's let's
pause before we jump to modern-day
because everything that you just
described there was why I thought your
bio is so interesting because you grow
up with communists you know now you know
about the guys I didn't know about the
guy in the basement but you I mean you
you are firmly on the left your whole
first 40-some idea and martha wrote a
book called empire and revolution which
the Blessed use right so leftist
communist marxist I mean so Paul Berman
for example said of the above my book
that it was like a I don't know what he
said a handbook a Bible for they for the
left before it called me a renegade for
leaving the left right right so that's
so you're you're a hero that but the
second you now change now of course if
you deviate from the party line we have
like political people don't realize
political correctness is a term that Mao
Zedong the greatest mass murderer in
human history invented to shut people up
it's the party line if you deviate from
the party line they throw you into the
cold yeah all right so now we're let's
flash forward unless there's something a
to you or shoot you right so they
generate a violent e of M s Union you
know
so unless I'm missing something I think
we can flash forward now to around 85
which is really when you that's why what
happened was when this happened I was
writing I had left ramparts with Peter
Collier who was my buddy and with Peters
idea that would
to write a dynastic biography but the
Goldsworthy saga was on PBS at the time
when so a generational saga so I was in
the midst of writing a book on the
Rockefellers which became a best-seller
and then we were asked to do a book on
the Kennedys which came out in 1985 and
in 1980 and and when it came out it was
the number one New York Times bestseller
and the Washington Post the editor of
The Washington Post Sunday magazine
called me to pick my brain about young
John Kennedy was a congressman and he
said what have you guys been doing AHA
you won't believe this but Peter and I
just voted for Ronald Reagan in need of
you and I had talked before casting that
bone Wow oh that's a good story you want
to write it so our story was better run
than read but he renamed it lefties for
Reagan right so then and that's when the
knives came out and Peter said to me at
the time I just show you how deeply
current brought the fake news is we were
fun page New York Times mm-hmm both
books both the Rockefellers and Sunday
Times and The New York Times sets the
standard for all the meetings they even
reprint them we've used but and when our
article came out on it and we voted for
Reagan Peter said to me our literary
careers are over Wow I said you must be
joking so you really had no idea I know
I work well I was even though you knew
some of the tactics and all but it was
exactly right at the end I don't write
last 20 bucks seven-year time they
noticed one they called me a relic for
using the word communist it was just as
good right so even though you knew all
the tactics that could be coming down
your way and the way you've never been a
realist about that before you so that
it you just weren't a realist in your
own even though you saw you did such a
history of seeing what would happen not
the Harrington communism black man I can
never believe that people can be you
know so ideological and so Dupin I
should know yeah I think I'm suffering
from a little of this right now and I'm
needed the rubbers meeting the road with
me at the moment of nature what what was
it about was it something about Reagan
or was it really about Mondale's Reagan
yeah was that happened earlier my
Bunsen's into the parking light of the
Berkeley co-op which is a supermarket
and was we everybody liked because it
was a cooperative when that Rolling
Stone actually published a story that
Peter and I did on the weather
The Weather Underground telling the
truth about it and this woman I do that
me in the pouring wine she said David
you know people really hate you now are
they truth about these crazy terrorists
is what they were
who got people killed and they hate you
not anything for saying the truth about
yeah but which but what was it about
Reagan also that then they hate a Reagan
the way I hate Trump yeah it was the
same kind of hatred which is a ticket
they just paid it's because he sees not
one of us it's very visceral yeah is
that was earlier with anything ironic
yeah he's not one of them you know he
was an act and you know he I don't know
the Trump phenomenon and problem is a
little different but it's not all that
different I mean Reagan was an actor
that they look down on that
you know von mises was a pamphlet Kohli
an essay which is a pamphlet called the
anti-capitalist mentality
why do academics hate capitalism why are
they so left and the answer is because
they feel superior
businessman piers Trump the businessman
businessman are Yahoo's they have no
respect to what it takes to build a
billion-dollar empire epidemics or theft
or something underhanded it's better
it's crony capitalism so Reagan was like
that he was an actor how dare he because
we're so much smarter than he is we
should be running the country so
intellectuals day I think was about
intellectuals generally they know what
they feel it they're smarter than
everybody else right because they
haven't actually created for the most
part they have to sort Ellen I want the
patent I think the power should go to
them and I learned very early when I was
still left when Jack Kennedy was
assassinated and Lyndon Johnson became
president I was living in England and of
course Europeans look down on Americans
from the beginning of the Republic but
LBJ he had the LBJ cufflinks and the LBJ
children and the LBJ dogs and he you
know was so they they just studies this
is a yahoo this is a you know and
Johnson was much smarter than Jack
Kennedy he went to East Texas State
Teachers College but he he unfortunately
he put in place the Great Society which
is an albatross on America's neck has
been for lo these this half-century but
he was smart he knew how to get it
through Congress and Jack Kennedy
couldn't get any of it through
yeah and now Congress barely works oh no
that's why when Trump came along I
wasn't one of these never trumping
inside the beltway snob although some of
my my good friends is that bad
you